i love inspiration and motivation but it  is the neurological equivalent of candy  it's rad it has its place but  everyone because those just happen to be  fleeting neurological states yeah you  just have to find something that's way  more grounded you need a mission you  need a grand why you need to know what  it is and this is not a discovery it's a  thing you decide so it's like you decide  and then you point yourself at something  nothing is ever going to feel right like  this is what i was put on earth to do it  won't feel that way until about a year  or two years after you've been saying  that's what you're gonna do that that's  what you're committed to and actually  acting in accordance with it and then  you'll be like yeah this actually is my  mission